so just Billy does he have any hidden
talents is he the music he loves playing
bang on the drums all the time he has an
uncanny knack to find the most dangerous
thing in the room and you know put it in
his mouth for us that stick his tongue
and it lights up that's a kid for you
right yeah he's the most beautiful baby
and he's just so innocent you want to
work together right yeah like this show
I've never seen join up any face ever
than this kid today what he was swimmin
I think swimming it yeah you wanna
protect the middle because you love it
so much so you know I mean that's gonna
have more yes I thought I think if I
ever if he ever leaves me and my wife
alone for you know that's what happens
when you have a baby you don't have a
lot of alone time together but we are we
would love to have known us you need to
see godly young like she can you know
what do you learn and it what I'm
learning is you can see why there's so
many messed up people's work because it
takes so much time or haitians my wife
has energy
kindness love right yeah love it it
happen
now I'm glad that I mean yeah you know I
say that all the time to you that I
would glad I have mine later in life
it's also like we've done everything
right I mean I've done everything three
times and it's this and this is the best
part I want you to have five more that's
a lot yeah but as much as you love being
a dad why love it
well cuz I want to be able to give as
much like a gift to this I think I
[Music]
[Applause]